What kind of curve is uniquely
defined by these two points? A
line.
How about three points? A
circle.
This basic geometry is ancient
history. Euclid
proved it more than two thousand years ago
in his seminal math treatise "Elements."
Now try to figure out the shape of a curve that passes through a million points in a 1,000 dimensions
and is super twisty. What would that look like?
Although daunting, finding a solution to this problem is
fundamental to probing deeper
principles of math. And the
solution also holds the
potential to improve digital
data storage, the security of
your crypto wallet, and the
privacy of electronic
communications. It's called the
interpolation problem. And two
young mathematicians, Eric
Larson and Isabel Vogt of Brown
University have solved it.
The interpolation problem asks,
If you fix some general
collection of points, when is
there a curve of some specified
type through those points?
In search of answers, the pair
chipped away at the problem for
years,
We started out tackling cases in
small dimensional spaces to try
to get our hands dirty and see
the sort of techniques that we
would need. And then I think
around 2019 or so we came up
with a good idea that we thought
might help us solve the whole
problem.
Along the way, their
collaboration took on a whole
new dimension,
Well, we got married in 2017.
Much of the groundwork for a
potential solution was laid out
150 years ago by German
mathematicians, Alexander von
Brill and Max Noether
Before you can ask what
properties does a given type of
curve have, you need to first
answer the question of what
types of curves are there?
The theorem predicts what types
of curves can exist based on
three properties. The first is
dimension,
You can think about a curve in
actual physical space, that
would be a three dimensional
space. But we don't constrain
ourselves to two dimensions or
three dimensions.
The second quantity is the
degree of a curve.
So you should think, here, like
how twisty or wobbly the curve
is.
The third is the genus or number
of holes a curve has.
Curves themselves, have a sort
of topological property. But if
you were to look at the
solutions over the complex
numbers, then it's going to look
like something that's two
dimensional. So it could look
like a sphere. Or it could look
like the surface of a doughnut.
Or it could look like the
surface of a two-hole doughnut.
In general, it can have any
number of holes.
It wasn't until the 1980s that
modern math offered a proof of
Brill-Noether. And this opened
doors to the interpolation
problem. Larson and Vogt, we're
determined to solve the problem
for all possible types of
curves.
We had to come up with three
different ways of breaking the
curve into simpler curves. So we
take some curve, it's
complicated, it's very wobbly.
So we take this wobbly curve,
and we break it in three
different ways.
By breaking down the complex
curve in multiple steps, Larson
and Vogt were able to get
something simple enough that
they could attack it with their
bare hands.
We knew how slippery it was, how
you really had to work hard to
get everything to match up,
Larson and Vogt's proof
confirmed the interpolation
problem in all cases, showing
that curves will always
interpolate through the expected
number of points with only four
exceptions, which they also
explained. The couple's proof is
a powerful tool for exploring a
whole new class of ideas.
Bit of a surprise to finally complete it,
you know, it's you've just been
thinking, oh, this is what I do
is I work on this problem, but
then you're like, wow, it's
done.
More than 2,000 years ago, the
Greek mathematicians Zenodorus
argued that a sphere is the
optimal shape of a single
bubble. This may seem obvious,
but it took until the late 19th
century to prove it
mathematically. What about a
cluster of multiple bubbles?
Researchers study bubbles to
both better understand their
geometric properties and
potentially improve everything
from computer algorithms and
biological cell models to
firefighting foams. For decades,
mathematicians have sought the
optimal configuration of larger
bubble clusters. But it turns
out the solution is one of the
hardest problems in geometry.
The bubble problem can be stated
simply: What configuration of
bubbles encloses a given number
of volumes while minimizing
surface area.
And the key point is that the
surfaces are allowed to, like, if I
smashed my bubbles together I'm
allowed to save the surface
that's between them. I mean,
it's an optimization problem.
And that's such a universal kind
of problem with all kinds of
applications.
From our own experience of
blowing bubbles, we know that
larger clusters of bubbles tend
to form tight clumps rather than
a long chain. But how can we
know whether these formations
are actually optimal?
In the 1990s, John Sullivan, now
of the Technical University of
Berlin, formed a guiding
conjecture,
He described what we now call a
standard bubble or a standard
bubble cluster. They're spheres.
They meet at 120 degree angles.
They all touch. There could be
lots of different ways to
achieve that. It turns out that
that's not the case.
Sullivan's conjecture states, if
the number of volumes you want
to enclose is at most one
greater than the dimension,
there's one cluster
configuration, that's the best.
There's basically one way to
achieve this and his conjecture
was that this way is the optimal
way.
To visualize Sullivan's optimal
cluster place four points
equidistant on a sphere. Inflate
the points into bubbles or disks
on the surface until they bump
into each other. Keep inflating
them until the entire sphere is
covered. We end up with a
symmetric cluster that all touch
and meet at 120 degree angles.
Now place the sphere on a flat
plane. Add a light at the north
pole to cast a two dimensional
shadow of three bubbles. Rolling
the sphere around creates
clusters of Sullivan's shadow
bubbles that can enclose any
three areas.
By 2002, mathematicians had proved
Sullivan's conjecture for the
double bubble. And at this
point, some speculated another
100 years would pass before a
proof for three bubbles could be
found. But then Emanuel Milman
of Technion University, and Joe
Neeman of the University of
Texas, Austin entered the
picture.
So what we were working on was
sort of the probabilistic
version of this problem. And we
were interested, actually,
originally, we were just we
would have been happy to do
double bubble at the beginning.
We were like, you know, we have
to come up with something new.
Right. And so we came up with
some new things.
After some success solving the
analogous probabilistic bubble
problem, the pair hit a snag
transferring their new
techniques to the geometric one.
So we were stuck on this for a
long time. And definitely a
breakthrough came when we
actually, we kind of gave up to
be honest.
Milman and Neeman realized that
if you give bubbles, one extra
dimension of space, you get a
bonus: The best bubble cluster
will have mirror symmetry across
a central plane.
We were like, okay, let's give
up on what we were trying to do
and see what we can get from the
symmetry. And then as soon as we
had that symmetry that, you
know, that symmetry combined
with what we had been working on
for the previous three years,
all of a sudden, like then we
were able to move on from there.
But Milman and Neeman's proof
of Sullivan's conjecture for
triple bubbles in dimensions
three and up is not the end of
the story.
We're stuck at a maximum of five
bubbles right now. But I feel
like it's just like a tiny
little thing that we are not
seeing and then that problem
will go away.
Take a set of points and start
randomly connecting them with
lines. At what point will an
interesting pattern emerge? Like
a triangle or a Hamiltonian
cycle, a chain of lines that
passes through each point
exactly once. In a branch of
math called combinatorics,
graphs like these are valuable
tools for probing the inner
workings of complex systems.
A graph is just another name for
a network.
Networks are everywhere like
Facebook network. You can think
about traffic networks, you
know, or business networks and
things like that.
But real life networks can be
huge and hard to study. So
mathematicians use random graphs
to model their properties.
In the random graph theory,
finding thresholds is a central
subject. People worked on
finding threshold for each of
interesting properties.
Interesting properties can
emerge as you increase the
density of lines in a random
graph. The sudden moment of
change is defined by a
threshold. In nature thresholds
are responsible for abrupt
transformations and the
emergence of complex patterns.
But it turns out that
determining threshold is
extremely difficult.
Instead, mathematicians use a
method to arrive at a ballpark
figure.
There is a very natural lower
bound to the threshold that we
call the expectation threshold.
The expectation threshold turns
out to be much easier to
estimate or determine.
In 2006, mathematicians Jeff
Kahn and Gil Kalai posed their
expectation threshold
conjecture. It states that the
gap between the expectation
threshold and the real threshold
is at most a logarithmic factor,
but sometimes smaller, or even
nonexistent.
The Kahn-Kalai conjecture just
gives one simple solution to
find out the location of the
threshold for many, many
interesting properties. So it's
just so powerful, and it was
hard to believe that this
conjecture is true.
That was until two
mathematicians at Stanford,
Jinyoung Park and Huy Pham,
stumbled onto an elegant six
page solution after a long
sleepless night.
It really came about by really
not working or aiming directly
at the Kahn-Kalai conjecture.
It was a surprise that we found
out another way.
The pair were instead working on
several related conjectures.
Like, you know, you're like
taking a walk that you aim at a
seemingly very different and
distant destination, but on the
way, you are suddenly able to
find some very surprising hidden
beauty.
A key breakthrough was the
realization that a method
developed in the pursuit of one
conjecture could be used in a
different manner to solve
Kahn-Kalai. The solution
utilized a mathematical object
called a cover.
You can think about a cover as
essentially a kind of necessary
condition, a witness to the fact
that the network satisfies the
properties.
Park and Pham employed an
algorithm to sample subsets of a
random graph to home in on the
cover.
In the end, we verify this cover
is small, in particular, so that
is exactly how we prove the
conjecture.
Park and Pham's concise proof of
Kahn-Kalai is expected to lead
to new breakthroughs.
This would allow us to get a
much better handle on complex
properties of networks and this
is certainly usefull in many
applications not just in math
or in probabilistic
combinatorics, because networks
are involved everywhere.